thousands of children are currently
isolating
why wait until next term to end the
bubbles why not get the kids back in
school now
they've already cost them months of
education parents are desperate why not
act now
i want to say a massive thank you to to
parents and to
to teachers to pupils for everything
that they've been going through
throughout the
pandemic and i understand people's
frustration
uh when uh whole classes whole bubbles
are sent uh sent home when people are
asked
to isolate so what's happening now is
that public health england
and the scientists are looking at uh
the advantages the possibilities of
going to testing
uh rather than isolation they haven't
concluded
uh yet so what i want to do is just to
be
cautious as we go forward to that
natural fire break
of the of the summer holidays and uh
when i think that the risk in schools
will greatly diminish
and just ask people to be a little bit
patient
but in the meantime what we must do is
keep on uh vaccinating the uh
the adults of the population so that
they're protected
against the infection and that is going
well and you can see that even though
cases are going up
uh in young people it's not feeding
through
into serious disease and death in the
older generation
also frustrated are those double
vaccines
waiting for a dividend from this they've
done what you've asked they've got their
jabs they still can't go on holiday will
they be able to travel from the 26th of
july as
is reported i'm very confident that paul
i'm very confident that the
the double jabs uh will be a
liberator uh and they will enable uh
people to uh to travel uh we'll be
sending out a lot more about the detail
of that in
the course of july and of course of the
next few days
about how we see it working but there's
no doubt at all that once you've got two
jabs
uh you are in a in a much better vision
obviously as
as everybody can see we'll be going
forward in the autumn
uh with an extra vaccination program
like a booster program
for the more vulnerable just to give us
that extra insulation that extra
security that we need but certainly to
answer your point
everybody who's frustrated about uh
travel over the summer
uh double jabs will be a liberator but i
want to repeat the point that i've made
before i hope people will forgive me if
i say that um
i do want obviously i want travel to be
to be possible
but i've got to stress that you know
this year will not be like every other
year because of the difficulties we've
covered you know people shouldn't expect
it would be
completely hassle-free thank you last
one if i may
you may have watched wimbledon last
night the roof's closed it's a giant
indoor event with thousands of people
not wearing masks if it's good enough
for wimbledon and the oxford vaccine
team were there on monday with the
rooftop that's good enough for them
why can't pubs clubs theaters get on
with opening up
drop the restrictions drop masks and do
what clearly people are allowed to do at
the tennis
obviously because what uh they do with
those those pilot events
is they have a special testing regime
and make sure that everybody
who comes in is properly uh tested and
and there's very very little risk of of
infection
i know that people are impatient for us
to to open
up up faster and of course i i want to
do that but
what i'm saying was we're now in the
final furlong i really believe
uh we have to look very carefully at the
at the dayton at the moment
and what we're certainly seeing is a big
increase in in cases
uh 26 000 as as you will have seen
but that is not uh translating uh
into a big increase in serious uh
illness and
and death and so it looks ever clearer
that we have broken the vaccination
program
the speed of that vaccine rollout has
broken that link
between infection and mortality
and that's an amazing thing that gives
us the scope
we think on the 19th to go ahead
cautiously
uh irreversibly to go ahead on the 19th
are you going to have the courage of
your convictions and say
distancing will go masks will go it will
actually be normal
rather than a a neutered version of real
life
i know how impatient people are to to
get back to total
normality as indeed am i and
uh we will be setting out i'll be
setting out in the course of the next
few days
what uh step four will look like exactly
but
i think i i've i've said it before we'll
be wanting to
to go back uh to a world that is as
close
to the status quo anti-uh
as possible to try to get back to life
as close to
uh it was before kogan but there may be
some things we have to
to to to do some extra precautions that
we have to take
but i'll be sending all that out